the session all of you are able to stand
up here and give a talk about why we
need three by three yeah and to get that
we need to the emotional component was
beautifully put forward by a hundred
ways now let's talk about the brain for
a little bit
the rationale so why do we need to
protect anything right and then how much
and then where and how and then the
final question of course how much is it
going to cost right so this is what
we're going to try to do in the next
twenty minutes somebody shaved five
minutes out of our session wonderful
okay I start with why so you guys know
we have to be concise why what what is
there any problem what's the problem
what are the drivers of this global laws
of nature that we hear about please
thanks very much we all were probably
aware of a recent UN report which said
that a million species are threatened
with extinction and this includes 60% of
all large mammals which includes
elephants rhinos great apes imagine a
world without them it could 60% of all
turtles and tortoises and there was the
report came out just last week that said
that in fact plants are becoming extinct
at an even greater rate than animals
with about 600 species of plants that
have gone extinct in the last 250 years
and why is it happening well one of the
core reasons that it's happening is
there's a lot more of us than there were
so where National Geographic was founded
in 1888 there were about 1.5 billion
people on the planet now there's more
than 7.7 billion so that means we need
land for agriculture and about
three-quarters of the world's land area
and most of the world's oceans are now
impacted in some way by human activities
we only have 15 percent of the original
tropical forests remaining and only
about 5% of the world's natural
grasslands remaining on top of that we
over exploit individual species by over
logging over hunting overfishing which
means
that's the greatest threat to certain
species such as elephants tigers a lot
of the ones that we really care about
and it matters and why should we care
about it partly because as we've heard
in a lot of talks this week so far these
species have intrinsic value if they're
really special and that's the basis of
the Endangered Species Act lots of other
national legislations and international
treaties because we believe these
species have a right to exist they also
have huge cultural value they're bound
into the cultures of people around the
world they're also extremely important
for local livelihoods so local people
are very particularly indigenous and
traditional communities are very
dependent on wild species for their
livelihoods about a billion people
worldwide depend on wild fish for their
basic protein supply and perhaps in some
ways most important of all they provide
essential ecosystem services in these
biodiverse systems which keep us alive
by mitigating climate change by
controlling the climate by controlling
water supplies so for all those reasons
we're losing things and it really
matters you must be like me
I've never invited back to a party
it's a lot of stats and it's very
depressing but that's the truth right
now that's the truth we have transformed
we are like that we are like the
meteorite that caused the extinction of
the dinosaurs right and it's we're
transforming apply that at a geological
scale the good news because I don't want
you guys to walk out of this auditorium
depressed is that we can reverse that
right and this is what we're going to
focus on protected areas that provide at
hands your can and many other people
here have been working on in the ocean
we see this very clearly you know when
you stop killing the fish what happens
they take a longer time to die they grow
larger they have more sex and produce
lots of babies and these particulate
areas in the ocean bring back life
spectacularly you know with my colleague
and explore Octavia Bordeaux here in
Mexico in 1999 we went to a place called
cabo pulmo in Baja California
that place was part of a study we did
across the Gulf of California Mexico and
it was not nothing remarkable about that
place it was as degraded as the rest of
the Gulf of California and the fishermen
were so upset with not having enough
fish to catch that they decided to do
something that nobody expected
they stopped fishing completely they
created they convinced the Mexican
government to create a national park
cabo pulmo national park we returned ten
years later and you probably have seen
this photo that octavia took of a little
diver david and goliath with a humongous
school of thousands of jacks
what had been a desert was now a
kaleidoscope of life and color the
Sharks were back the jacks the groupers
we saw it go from degraded to pristine
in only ten years so when we give space
to nature nature comes back you know
spectacularly and same thing same thing
on the land and we know that this these
protected areas are the best way to
bring back all that nature of that
biodiversity but
how do we create the product area and
allow your Steve to tell us about you
know in a place as unknown to most
people as Angola right how do you go
about creating a national park near a
protected area
well first we must acknowledge that I
mean our planet's last well places are
those places that for whatever reason
our modern society never settled or
developed places that we hardly ever go
places protected by their remotes in
accessibility but now as I said we have
almost 8 billion people on the planet we
are entering these lost
Eden's I'll be going there to destroy
them I'm not sure but I do know that
it's our cities that and not the local
communities not the bushmeat hunters
themselves that are eating and wearing
our last wildlife now before I go into
the house I just want to take a moment
for us all to acknowledge the indigenous
local communities that live in these
last world places the stewards and
custodians who are too often
underrepresented in meetings and
conferences like this around the world
[Applause]
there are the guardians of the central
banks of global biodiversity these last
wild sanctuaries for the plants and
animals we depend on so they are the key
now in our working in the Angolan
highlands in a landscape that we call
the Okavango Zambezi water tower they
have guided us in finding 70 new species
to science currently being described 93
new species franco hundreds of species
not known to be there they've guided us
to 19 sauce lakes surrounded by
stratified peat deposits peatlands they
were not known to be the undocumented
fundamentally changing our understanding
of the functioning of incredibly
important river systems like the
Okavango wanda and there's mbz
now in our interactions with government
which is incredibly important that's
where the policy is going to come from
that's when you protected areas is going
to come from early on they said what is
the name of this landscape now note this
landscape is the size of the state of
Wisconsin it's about 10,000 people
living in it
there was no name for it in government
no one in government had been there for
50 years so our team going in to view
the local communities asked them what is
the name of this place and there are
many names for small parts of it but
they wanted a name for the whole thing
and the name they come up with and
promoted was the similar Yama wanna
which means the source of life want to
the vendor now to take in our 57
scientists working on the project for
years to figure that out something they
had known all that time they will be our
guides in building this new future and
steady by 30 but now we have this
incredible scientific foundation that
we've created in the Okavango wilderness
project 60 publications are coming out
into scientific journals but that's
often where they stay what brings
National Geographic into a place where
it has so much impact is we can do
conservation media we can translate that
science into inspiration at all levels
in society from those policymakers to
the general public to those local
communities on the ground that is the
magic of this we need to catalyze this
process those scientific papers sitting
in a journal will take 20 years to
create a protected area in
then that landscape has been degraded on
the trajectory run right now so now we
have to create platform for these
discussions in these countries we're not
just working in Angola it's with
Botswana and Namibia sharing information
between those countries conferences
suppose you stakeholder meetings
meetings at all levels we're constantly
meeting with people there building
capacity building knowledge inspiring
them to take this on for themselves we
can't be prescriptive I don't come from
Angola I don't come from Namibia I don't
come from Botswana so my position is
simply to explore to illuminate and to
activate and that is what we do in the
Okavango wilderness project and that is
what we're gonna do in the lost world
places program can paint for nature it
has to happen as a global movement we
can start with banning plastic straws
but we have to get to the point where
we're welcoming biodiversity and
wildlife into our cities and creating
protected areas and landscapes and
sanctuaries for global biodiversity
because we all depend on it
thank you Steve and you mentioned the
science you mentioned the media but
alone science the media are just tools
right and it's all about people and we
have a we conduct with a survey around
the world 12 countries and other
institutions have conducted similar
surveys around the world and when people
are asked how much of the planet you
thing is protected now or you think they
say they say Oh 30% is already protected
at least said that only 15% of the land
is protected and then also only 5% of
the ocean is protected and when you ask
people how much do you want of the
planet protected and they say
overwhelmingly half you know 50% people
want a balance and actually what people
want is what the science is telling us
we need half of the planet in natural
state with functioning forests
grasslands wetlands peat bogs mangrove
forests seagrass beds healthy ocean
habitats
so nature can continue providing all
these wonderful benefits like oxygen
flood protection coastal protection food
pollination etc etc to provide for us
and for the rest of life on the planet
and this 30% of the planet in protected
areas by 2030 is the necessary milestone
we need more we need have
when half of the planet in natural
functioning state but this 30% by 2030
is why we have partnered with a wish
foundation and this campaign for nature
and it's very easy we only need to
convince 196 countries by October next
year next year in China in October
there's going to be a meeting which is
going to be the equivalent of the Paris
climate meeting but for for for nature
and this is what we want to do but then
the next question is where we're talking
about 30 percent but were that 30
percent should be and least you've been
taught you've been thinking a lot about
how to prioritize the areas where should
we prioritize place the rotated areas
now before it's too late yeah I'm more
on the terrestrial side and you can chip
in on the marine side but in terms of
where on the terrestrial side it's these
last great strongholds for biodiversity
it's not the sort of degraded places on
the outside it's got to be these last
great strongholds and that in a lot of
places is in intact forests intact
forests on land contain 80 percent of
terrestrial biodiversity and so that's
clearly a focus that we've got got to go
for in addition intact forests are
really important in mitigating climate
change they absorb about twenty percent
of all human produced carbon every year
and so keeping them in that intact state
is really important as a tool we're not
going to reach the Paris goals without
keeping our intact forests and they're
clearly also home to a large number of
traditional and indigenous peoples
around the world fitting into what Steve
said that they're going to be the last
guardians of these forests in many ways
and the other place is on land which are
really critically important to these
areas with very high biomass which of
animals of wildlife which tend to be the
big natural grasslands which have been
lost even more than forests have and so
those are the places of the last great
migrations and the last great also human
pastoralists in those areas so if we can
focus on those and I'm sure you can say
where we should be focusing on in the
sea that's another panel no that's great
and so you know we know that for
especially tropical forest harbor most
of the biodiversity more most of the
species on the planet
right because by diversity there is no
place that is better for biodiversity
than others by diversity is the variety
of life on Earth is just represented in
different trends and patterns right that
plays with a thousand species per
hectare in the tropical forest is as
valuable as a place with only ten
species in the Arctic it's just
different manifestations of life but you
know before going to that place in
Angola Steve before the sixty research
papers there was no much information
there right actually that was like a
black hole and the knowledge of
biodiversity in Africa so why did you
decide to go there how do you prioritize
without having that information oh I try
personally first and that was a lot to
do with National Geographic for about
2001 through until 2015 14 my entire
world was just this Okavango Delta in a
twenty thousand square kilometers in
northern Botswana this incredible
wilderness and I would explore it in my
macaw or across that every three hundred
and forty kilometers about 200 miles
take us eighteen days and have these
incredible experiences documenting its
biodiversity and then I came here I
became an emerging Explorer in 2013 and
it was I didn't really realize what was
going on then I was so over awed by it
but then in 14 I got to know inari and
many other explorers and I suddenly
broke us of the Okavango Delta my brain
opened and I came back middle of the
year June from the symposium the
festival and within a few months team
members were up in Angola we were making
contact with governor's I followed them
a month later and four five months later
we were in armored vehicles driving to
the source of the creature that had not
been documented all the information that
we had it was the we saw these these
lakes these wetlands they were said to
be wetlands filled with rain water
seasonally we get that we find these
ancient specific source lakes
surrounded by by these pigeons the the
government i sat with this governor
every powerful man
powerful men in the country in his
palace in Manong the capital of that
province and I explained over 45 minutes
with my translator exactly what I'm
going to do I'm going to explore these
rivers I'm going to look for new species
I mean do all these things and he stops
me it's a big man with a kind of ivory
Ken and he says stop I have one big
problem with this project
he said you National Geographic I wanted
you in 2002 to come to Angola and see
the new Angola
you are welcome I will give you anything
you need and there was this unique
opening
I was talking to Carter Roberts from WWF
naturally called it - these are one of
these unique openings that we have to
grasp onto and come in we're talking
about a landscape that is the size of
the state of Wisconsin we're talking
about the primary water supply for the
calving goose mbz transplant tier
Conservation Area the largest such
conservation area in the world home to
more than half of the elephants
remaining on the planet it's an
incredibly important landscape but I'm
the kind of person that is so focused on
what I'm doing my brain starts to open
up on these expeditions it was one of
our photographers
he asked me Steve we're sitting on the
creature River what is to the east of us
it's just four hundred kilometres of
baldness and he asked me he said to me
well why don't you try and protect it'll
help this government protect it and
again it happened and I started to try
and think about that and that's been our
mission for the rest of this time
culminating and signing this protocol of
cooperation on the 4th of December 2018
it's a five-year agreement with the
Angolan governments can work with those
communities to build a system of clocks
that they to protect this landscape
and I hope that there is the Bing going
on in the minds of many young explorers
now and I'll talk a little bit about the
ocean okay
so the last ten years with the project
pristine seas we have been going to the
wildest places in the ocean places where
we are still you know you jump in the
water and you are immediately surrounded
by sharks and this is something that
made the Chinese laugh last week it's a
whole you like sharks and I say well the
different way that you like them and so
we have been working with partners and
governments using this combination of
exploration research and media to
inspire governments around the world to
create 21 of the largest marine reserves
covering an area of over 5 million
square kilometers have the size of
Canada and I'd like to thank our friend
John Podesta who's here today because he
won in his latest years at the White
House he was instrumental in expanding
our national marine monuments in the
Pacific so thank you John and we will
continue working not only on the ocean
but also on these new last world places
to try to help to protect some of these
key areas on the land that contains such
important biodiversity and the last
question is how much is it going to cost
so you have the Minister of the
Environment after we have convinced the
Minister of Environment or the president
of the country all we have to protect
this right you have the emotional
connection with the media wonderful yeah
I'm going to protect it and here's all
the science 60 papers you were not going
to read them but believe me they are
great and and then the Minister of
Finance says okay how much is it going
to cost and this is where we have the
problem how much does it cost to manage
the product area it depends how remote
it is it depends on the pressures on it
because broadly as I heard mister we're
saying in the previous section we've got
to maintain them not just establish them
because otherwise it's like leaving with
all these species that people value for
all the wrong reasons inside them it's
like leaving a bank without a guard so
there's one that I can just give you one
example of his newer Balian doki
National Park in northern congo it's a
fabulous national park it was one of the
parts founded as a result of mike phase
walk that we heard about earlier
and it it's about 4,000 square
kilometres it's on a very heavy poaching
pressure because it's got one of the
best last remaining populations of
African forest elephants in it as well
as gorillas and the whole bunch of other
stuff and that costs about 750 dollars
per square kilometre per year to protect
to do all the correct patrols and all
that sort of stuff
so we're talking about millions of
dollars potentially for lives per day
and this is the problem we the Minister
of Finance only here so you know we're
going to forego all these quick dollars
for timber right Plus every year's went
to cost us half a million a million or
whatever it is right so we don't have
money right that's the problem but what
these people don't communicate and the
Ministry of Finance don't know is that
particular areas produce enormous
benefits and you know seven hundred and
fifty dollars per head per square
kilometre in the US every dollar that
the US government invests in the
management of a National Park produces a
return of ten dollars ten fold return
that fits into the local economy it's
like you know you'd open a restaurant
and expect to have a net profit on day
one right same thing with protected
areas they provide huge benefits but we
need to to give them time and not only
economic benefits in cabo pulmo that
plays in Baja California those visionary
fishermen are now much better off
because they live off tourism and the
fishermen around that part are also
catching more fish and their incomes are
are higher and yesterday there was a new
scientific paper coming out saying that
marine protected areas that are fully
protected provide well-being benefits to
humans same thing for the land in
protected areas in developing countries
kids are more likely to be in good
health and to be higher for the same age
taller for the same age and do better
that's cool so protect areas have
benefits that extend well well beyond
beyond the boundaries and you mentioned
Greg Carr before Tracy great car is
for conservationists who have has been
involved in the restoration of the
Gorongosa National Park in Africa and he
told us that during the last cyclone
cyclone
edye that killed couple thousand people
in Mozambique a few months ago the
natural grasslands of the park absorbed
an amount of rain equivalent to eight
hundred thousand Olympic swimming pools
the be great the grasslands where the
the livestock has over grazed the
grasslands M it is like asphalt the
waterfalls and it just goes downstream
you have these floods so that Park
actually prevent a greater floods and
loss of life so there are all these
benefits that that come with with
protected areas and so what benefits do
you expect for Angola if those project
they have created at the mouth of the
rivers well they they get their history
back I mean the the big elephants you
see standing in the main rotunda at the
Smithsonian here in DC is the fennec OB
elephant now that elephant was shot by
yourself anak IV in 1955 in the part of
Angola we're working in this was
recognized as the largest ever land
animal ever seen and then shot now that
part of Angola was known as the living
room of Africa in 1961 when the elephant
was unveiled at the Museum National
Geographic in the September issue wrote
an article Angola unknown Africa from
emphasizing the cultures the landscapes
the fennec curvy elephant safari this
was way before we even knew about
Botswana Namibia was an D these
established industries now Angola was
going to have that but then in 1961 the
civil war the war of independence brakes
are now war in that country continues
till 2002 they got independence in 75
and then civil war broke up so it's
these four years were stolen from them
now many of you know water sector borgia
from our firm is one of the leaders and
up for an in our project you'll see them
tonight here somewhere I think where
your water
now water we've now made first contact
with the communities update these Lacaze
communities at long lean hungry ribbon
and we go and visit to me look at their
lives and the way they're living and
what this is to me says well you know my
life before the marae me Game Reserve
and Yakov an adulterer was very similar
to this we were hunting farming fishing
we had similar homes my dad at sandals
like that we made fishing traps is very
similar that's what that was our life
but he saw his life changed with the
marina game reserve being established he
became a hunter for a while he left that
to become a safari guide for 14 years he
now has an iPhone a land cruiser it's
good to go into school he's an
incredible family life and he said that
was stolen from these Angolan people he
thought kinship with them and he said
Steve we have to help them catch up
these 40 years they have lost so that's
what they get back thank you for my
Steve thank you okay how many people now
is ready to come up here and give a talk
about 30 by 30 oh man nobody no oh wait
hansjörg thank you so much for your
extraordinary commitment and leadership
and we are with you and this campaign to
help to protect as much of our planet as
possible thank you very much
[Applause]
any up no huh Wow now that's a tough job
conserving 30 percent of the planet by
2030 but we have reason for hope we have
people like this working hard in the
field working to conserve our planet
now many of our own human nature are
what we do affects the planet in very
harmful ways and that's one of the
things that we need to really think
about changing our everyday manners in
order to lessen our impact on the
natural world so National Geographic is
deeply committed to researching
solutions to prevent plastic from
entering the oceans so last year
National Geographic launched Planet or
plastic a global multi-year initiative
to raise awareness and help try to solve
the devastating impacts of single-use
plastic and right now my team is in
India helping with the National
Geographic team and we're gonna get on a
Skype call with Heather and she's going
to tell us more about the project that
they're working on to stop the flow of
plastic into the ocean so here to tell
us more about our all-female expedition
team working to track plastic from cedar
source in India marine biologist and
National Geographic fellow Heather
Holloway
[Applause]
we just want to show a short video that
highlights the plastic pollution problem
1 million plastic water bottles have
sold every minute millions of tons of
plastic waste enters our ocean every
year
plastic can take lifetimes to decompose
leaving our planet drowning in waste our
planet is in trouble we're reaching a
crisis point when it comes to plastic
pollution but it's also solvable that's
why we at National Geographic are asking
our global community of change makers to
join us in choosing planet or plastic
from the pages of our magazine to the
work of our scientists and explorers we
are using our voice to connect with
millions and drive change
we've launched a global multi-year
initiative to reduce plastic waste in
our ocean
we're supporting research to answer key
questions we're tracking this plastic
from source to see and fund innovative
solutions all the exterior facade is
made from hundred percent recycled
plastic bottles we're empowering the
next generation of leaders by supporting
educators and engaging students whatever
lesson that I'm teaching I try to make
connections to the real world to the
environment into their personal lives
it's not something that's a next
generation problem its problem that we
need to solve now this starts with
people caring and when you care then you
make a difference we hope you'll join us
and help turn the tide on plastic waste
we are the ones that can do something
about it
I'm really excited to see how we can
solve this massive plastic problem
learn more at NatGeo org slash plastic
[Applause]
one month ago I found myself with my
team on this small blue boat we were
fighting wage that were crashing over us
a ridiculous current was swirling us
around and we were gently baking in 40
degrees C hundred degrees Fahrenheit in
old money heat but this isn't some ocean
survival story this is us at the start
of the National Geographic sea to source
expedition going to our first site in
the river Ganges to collect water
samples from the middle of the river
that at that point just happens to be
seven miles wide the river movement is
insane we were on a proper adventure
this river is immense it's one of the
most iconic rivers on the planet
culturally economically an incredibly
important from a biodiversity
perspective stretching 1600 miles from
the Bay of Bengal right up to the source
in the Himalayas and our job as Sita
sort expedition team was to work out how
to track plastic from its source to see
to work out where it was
coming from and more importantly how to
solve the plastic pollution problem
so why rivers we know from data that are
based on models that rivers are one of
the important contributors of plastic
pollution to the ocean and in those top
three rivers the Ganges is one of them
but these data are based on models just
looking at population and waste
management systems so we were the first
team ever to look at how we could go
globally to develop a methodology and a
comprehensive assessment system to work
out how to look at plastic and how this
is changing but first let me take you to
the team as a start point we are the
largest all-women team that National
Geographic has put together
[Applause]
we actually started to call this the
expedition of firsts firstly because I'm
job sharing expedition leadership with
Jenna John Beck professor at the
University of Georgia because we want to
show not only can women succeed in
science and conservation but you can
still be a mother and do so so we're
changing the parameter of exploration to
mean that we can really achieve we can
demonstrate that it's possible not to
choose between a family and career but
to deliver both at the same time we also
didn't start off explicitly saying this
would be all women we set off choosing
the best people for the job and they
just happened to be women and you'll see
here that as we thought about it we of
course brought on our in-country
partners working with the University of
Dhaka wild team and the Isabella
foundation in Bangladesh and the
wildlife Institute of India that we felt
there was a massive opportunity to show
the capability and strength and build
opportunities for women in science
technology engineering and maths and
bring them on board to really create a
united goal of making a difference and
delivering this expedition together so -
back to being on the boat around this
methodology you're traveling an enormous
river system you're spending three to
four days at each site and you're really
trying to understand everything that's
going on so to do this our team is very
diverse
we're biologists we're ecologists were
engineers we're technology experts we're
anthropologists with social scientists
and with storytellers and we are pulling
together all of these methodologies at
each site to make a difference so on the
water is measuring microplastics in
sediment and in water we're looking at
collecting plastic particles from the
air to understand where plastic is in
air pollution we're doing a threat
assessment of plastics on wildlife in
the river particularly fish which are so
important for communities to eat and
then the fourth dimension of our work is
look at the people component firstly how
do they generate waste the University of
Georgia team have developed a citizen
science tool to measure plastic waste
marine debris tracker anybody can use
that and we're applying it to actually
systematically document the waste that
we see in these different systems we've
also taken methodologies transics and
quadrats photo quadrats from coral reef
science and applied them to map and
document and quantify complex systems of
waste and then we're experimenting in
that important transition between land
and water so we've created these eco
plywood drift cards that we're working
as a community engagement tool to deploy
in likely routes for plastics to go
through storm drains through side
channels into the main river and down
into the ocean these have a message on
them asking people to communicate by SMS
or whatsapp when they find one and we're
going to go back in the after the
monsoon and see how these have moved
through the system at the other end of
the spectrum from pieces of wood we have
really pioneering technology satellite
tracking mock up plastic bottles using
satellites and cellular to to see how
they move through the system and we're
drone mapping the transition between the
riverbank and the river but finally it's
about the people we have an amazing
socio-economic team who are working with
communities at each site we talk to
focus groups women waste pickers fishers
youth and decision-makers and we do have
salsa
we know that the informal waste sector
is a critical part of the solution but
obvious often ignored and that we have
to create inclusive solutions if we are
to make a difference this for me
is science with purpose it's exploration
that matters for us it's not a choice
it's all about planet and not plastic
but it's still an expedition underway I
rejoin it on Friday but now I'd like you
to take
to my colleagues live in India in the
field who are delivering this expedition
right now on the ground okay is there
any aren't they fabulous so this has
been an intense effort to show some of
the challenges of delivering science and
conservation in remote areas and that's
around the technology involved in
communicating what we're trying to do so
these guys have just come in from the
field today it is actually festival in
the Ganges celebrating the birth of a
Ganga we've delivered a community
cleanup and we've been out with a team
have been out doing their scientific
methodologies all day so this is what
they look like they are all amazing
honestly and this is this awesome team
Jen is right there in the middle at the
back waving there we go and she can't
even hear me this is how ever we work
together and wrap it up so I'm really
sorry that they had done it an awesome
film they've been working all night to
try and do this live feed and live
communications but as ever to prove that
it's live it doesn't work
okay thank you
well thank you Heather and I completely
understand technological problems being
based in India it's amazing we got that
much yeah so there's a lot of problems
out there in the field and so we've
spent this morning with some critical
threats facing our planet and our next
segment focuses on how we define reality
and inspire hope to move towards
solutions storytellers and educators are
some of the best at helping us define
the realities we live in so I am
especially happy to introduce you to two
speakers a storyteller and an educator
Pete Muller there's a photographer
multimedia reporter and National
Geographic fellow Andrew Mapp is the CEO
of outdoor afro and also a National
Geographic fellow welcome Pete
[Applause]
morning everybody I'd like I'd like to
start this morning by asking you just to
close your eyes please and when you do
this I'd like you to envision the place
that you call home wherever that may be
and I don't necessarily mean the house
that you live in but a place a place
that gives you a sense of comfort and
grounding and connection I'd just like
you to try to be there just for a moment
I'd like you to imagine that a
transformation happens in this
environment it starts to change the
characteristics of this place that
you've known and loved that's give you a
giving you the sense of comfort such
that you don't quite recognize it
doesn't feel familiar to you any longer
now depending on what causes this
transformation this feeling might be
difficult to articulate and express it's
complicated you can open your eyes I'd
like you to take you to a place this
morning where that's not an imagined
situation it's becoming a form of
reality this is the Upper Hunter Valley
it's this beautiful idyllic River Valley
about three hours north of the city of
Sydney in Australia and for most of its
history it's been known for beautiful
things thoroughbred horse breeding dairy
farms wine vineyards in the late 1990s
there was a discovery of high-quality
coal underneath the valley floor big
companies came in and started digging
big holes to get at it holes like this
this is the mount Thorley walk worth
mine and Singleton Shire it's a massive
massive hole it's visible from space
they started opening mines like this all
throughout the upper hunter and with it
came this sort of associated
transformative physical attributes and
this is all in this quiet place this is
Glenn Albrecht he's an environmental
philosopher and at the time Glenn became
interested in the emotional dimension
of what was happening to communities
that were living around these minds and
as the minds expanded the word of Glen's
interests in them and that experience
started to spread and his phone started
to ring and on the other end of the
phone were people like Wendy Bowman
Wendy live most of her adult life in the
valley she's been involved with a dairy
farming family and she was beside
herself she was fighting with mining
companies that were trying to acquire
parts of her her property she was
serving as an informal counselor for all
these other people were going through a
similar experience she couldn't sleep at
night she was carrying this sense of
emotional weight day and night Glen got
calls from people like John lamb the
tough guy was a former soldier he
thought issues of mental health and
emotional well-being for fuller for the
week that he was in control of his
experience through the energy of his
mind but as these holes got bigger
something in John broke no matter how
hard he tried to keep his energies up as
soon as he's confronted these Minds his
heart would just drop into his feet he
started driving 20 30 40 kilometres out
of his way to avoid these confrontations
Glen's started to get a lot of these
kinds of stories and he started to
notice this commonality among them
people knew that the mines were the
source of their distress but they had a
very difficult time articulating this
feeling
it was almost almost like a sense of
homesickness but nobody left home it was
almost like the their homes of or their
some essence of their homes had left
them and it wasn't really nostalgia
either because it wasn't purely looking
back at golden days gone by this was
about something being lost or something
kind of being taken in the present and
that had implications for the future
also as far as Glen could tell there was
no word to describe this experience and
without one people in the valley
couldn't explain
they were feeling to other people and
they couldn't really even make sense of
it to themselves so cleanse that down
with his wife and his intellectual
partner Jill and they decided to name it
enough of this people are experiencing
it they can't express it we have to name
it so they started thinking about what
exactly was underway what was this
feeling that people are having well
there was a pain a sort of longing an
algae the pain to return and this pain
related to people's homes and what are
our homes really they give us a sense of
comfort so Glen was thinking okay
comfort but how do I how could I modify
that word into a new word to describe
this well I got out this book of
synonyms and antonyms that Jill had had
from her school days then they looked up
the word comfort in there and there they
found a synonym solace to have a sense
of peace and Glen thought I think that
might work
so in a paper in 2003 Glen started to
call this complex emotional experience
of losing the sense of place he started
to call this solastalgia and it's since
become known as this idea of an
existential or psychic sense of distress
that's brought about by unwelcomed or
negative changes in a person's home
environment people started talking about
this they started making art about it
writing poetry having conferences and I
heard it years later in a film a
National Geographic documentary film and
my mother's living room tens of
thousands of miles away from where it
originated I thought wow what an
interesting idea this is a new frontier
in sort of examining and charting our
experience in this changing world and it
wasn't just about the physical changes
outside of us it was about how those
changes were being mirrored back within
us but if we lack words and terminology
and concepts to understand and identify
those things and share them perhaps
we're not seeing them for the prevalence
the prevalence at which they're
occurring
and maybe that is part of the problem so
I started to travel with this idea in
mind I went to Paradise California where
the campfire decimated that town last
November I spent time with people like
Gwen Norgren we see here sitting by the
pool of her former home she's to come
out through these double doors cut
across the walkway dive into the pool
float on her back and look with this
beautiful blue California sky I spent
time with Don Criswell sixth generation
parody gen deeply devoted to the town
deeply imbued with its sense of place
Don plays the piano and played all over
town the bars restaurants lodges used to
play the Rocky Mountain smokehouse here
you can see that on the left Don and I
talked a lot about what it was like to
lose that place but that stress and
experience was like what community meant
what rebuilding was going to mean
traveled high up into the Andes
Mountains in Peru if members of towards
the coiour et festival which is the snow
star festival with members of the
Quechua community there's an annual
pilgrimage that occurs to worship the
lord of the ice the lord of coiour et
trees Ides in a series of glaciers that
are melting at a rapid pace here we see
Pablito s-- at the base of the glaciers
before the ceremony at dawn talked about
the emotional role in the spiritual
dimensions of seeing these changes
travel to the far edge of the Russian
Arctic where coastal members of the
chuchi community are deeply reliant on a
healthy marine ecosystem around them
both for sustenance like we see here the
hunting of marine mammals like walruses
but also for a strong sense of identity
those communities eaters are noticing a
cup of an inconsistent formation of sea
ice these days which has dire
implications for the ecosystem the
health of the breeding grounds and
resting grounds for Pacific walruses and
I spend time when at the coast of
Louisiana on Isle de Jean Charles it's a
small island gets smaller each year it's
a place where coastal erosion and rising
sea levels have conspired to take nearly
90% of this land of this island over the
last 50 years and there I met Chantal
comer Dale we see Chantal sitting with
her father boyo and her son in this
picture this is four generations of
only a fifth represented in the pictures
on the wall Jen tells 37 and she shared
with me some really interesting
observations about the sense of and the
shape and contours of this loss and what
it's meant to her and I'd like to let
her speak for herself here communities
and there's a community in Alaska who's
had the same thing and we were able to
sit down and talk about things and it
was almost exactly the same feelings the
same emotion that they went through was
it it was like okay so I'm not alone I
don't this isn't just something I make
it up in my mind you know it was it was
real it became real it became real and
it came it became real in part because
Chantal knew that other people were
feeling it too that she wasn't alone we
are social animals we have a deep need
to understand ourselves and others
around us and connect over these things
and language is an important part of
that Chantal was able to close the
physical distance between herself and
that community in New Tok Alaska but
where that's not possible
words can build some of these bridges
and without them perhaps we are arguably
blind to the prevalence of these
experiences and the possibilities of
solutions to solve them thanks very much
narrative matters good morning my name
is room app founder and CEO of outdoor
afro and yes narrative matters thanks
Pete
I didn't see people who look like me
represented in natural spaces as I was
growing up in the same way that my
family was enjoying the outdoors my
parents came from Texas and Louisiana in
search of the warmth of other Suns to
California
leaving behind Jim Crow but bringing
with them a love of nature and
importantly the desire an imperative to
connect in nature with others so while
we live most of the time in Oakland
California we had this beautiful ranch
about a hundred miles north in Lake
County in this beautiful savanna of oak
rolling woodlands and it was truly my
laboratory but it was also a place where
we brought family together just as you
see depicted in this picture for all
kinds of celebrations but I can remember
how excited I was to jump out of the car
when we arrived at the ranch and head to
our local Creek to find out what was new
had the tadpole turned into a frog were
the rushing rivers trickling down in in
the heat of summer and back at the ranch
I noticed what was in bloom what was
ready to be picked and eaten and perhaps
can't and I had a very rich connection
to environmental education through the
Girl Scouts and yeah these are two pages
from my diary why right and big loopy
cursive how much I love the Girl Scouts
and how much I loved camping but
everything came together for me several
years later I was an outward-bound
student and I thought I could do
mountaineering since I had this long
connection to the outdoors why not try
it
but I found myself starfish on the side
of this mountain in Sequoia Kings and I
was about to give up when my instructor
who did not give up on me and neither
did that mountain my instructor leaned
over and said the magic words Roo trust
your feet and there was something
magical about those words that empowered
me to scramble up to the top and that
was the moment that I understood nature
as a powerful teacher there to teach me
exactly the lesson I needed to learn at
the precipice of adulthood I needed to
know that I had what I needed already
inside of me to move forward even if I
didn't know what was ahead of me or what
just happened that I could continue to
move forward and I'm still trusting my
feet so things came together for me
several years later I you know wanted to
do something different professionally
and I had a mentor ask me the question
that I think everyone should ask or
answer and that is of time and money
we're not an issue what would you be
doing and I opened my mouth and my life
fell out I said oh I probably started a
website to reconnect african-americans
to the outdoors and outdoor afro was
born and it was born at my kitchen table
and I just began to tell the story of
growing up wild and how I was connecting
my own children my own three children to
wild places and the value that it
provided for me but not only was a blog
born a community of leadership was born
and I'm so proud that using social media
I was able to connect with people who
had a narrative very similar to my own
and wanted to do something about it and
over the years we learn from each other
and we grew with each other and I'm so
proud by the ways that we have together
shift the visual representation of who
gets outside
but importantly who leads in the
outdoors
and these are ordinary everyday men and
women I called them the butcher the
baker the candlestick maker they come
from a wide tapestry of professional
backgrounds but they share this fire in
their belly to connect others to nature
and we now oversee a participation
network spanning 30 States of over
36,000 people and in a proud moment last
year a group of those leaders summited
Mount Kilimanjaro again teaching us that
we can we we can find a way to
understand life through life's climbs
we're also taking a step back often in
our work and remembering our and very
important history in the ways that we
have persisted and overcame in nature
even when nature was hostile to us we
can turn to the plaintive lyrics of
Billie Holiday's strange fruit to
understand that in the not so distant
past the outdoors the wilderness and
trees did not always represent safety
for black people but we have a new
testimony we have a way today to tell a
new narrative through this work and we
have the ability to just like our
foremothers did lay down our burdens
down by that riverside outdoor afro has
decided this year that we are going to
teach every child in our sphere of
influence to learn to swim why because
of Jim Crow because of decades of
exclusion from public pools from beaches
and coastal areas we have a public
health crisis where African American
children are drowning at five times the
rate of their white counterparts and
because we've built this trust in this
Network it's time for us to convert that
into action and we know that if a child
doesn't know how to swim
they're not going to put a pole in a
lazy lake
they're not going to take a ride in a
canoe and they're certainly not going to
care about plastic in the ocean so we're
very thankful for all the ways that we
can turn to nature for healing and
community just as my parents did and
take the time to get to know our species
that surround us in our relationship
with them and this picture here really
touches me this is a picture of Barbara
and her daughter through outdoor afro
experiencing snow for the very first
time people often ask me what will it
look like when your work is done
rooo when our work is done I don't think
it's going to be a mainstream but Main
Street parade with tickers falling from
the sky may not appear on the cover of a
national magazine I think it's going to
be this quiet moment when we all look up
and we see people outside recreative
protecting healing in nature in
proportion to their population and their
opportunity and it's no big deal thank
you
thank you thank you rue
okay so I know we've had a long morning
but we've got a lot more to cover it's
time for a super short break so if you
can we're already running behind time so
if you could go out stretch your legs
and come back as quickly as possible
we'll get the show started again thank
you all
[Music]